you know if you're 16 you have a lot of
time on your hands you may want to screw
around with trying to fix your windows
when it breaks if you're the same person
in your 25 and you still are not afraid
of the computer and you have a lot of
technical knowledge you suddenly find
you a bloodless time on your hands to
goof around with it and so it isn't a
question of being dumb or smart or or
intimidated or not intimidated it's a
question of you bought you bought the
laptop when you open it up you expect it
to come on you expected to connect to
the Wi-Fi network you expect it to get
you to the website you expect it to deal
with your email expect to be able to
play you know your favorite game on it
you expect to be able to deal with do
facebook in my space and at the same
time if you want to or need to you
expect to be able you know write a 50
page paper on it that's what they
promise you when they sell you the
computer and they don't promise you that
you're going to be spending your time
dealing with defragging the hard drive
and you know updating the security
program and all that other stuff and so
I have been laser-focused on that the
first line of my first column was
personal computers are just too hard to
use and it's not your fault and I still
think that's true and I think it's true
for cell phones which are like personal
computers ten years ago it's true for
most of these products